I know you said that they didn't really
give you a reason just that they didn't
have a partner I do have a theory okay I
think maybe you're gonna be coming too
big you have too many fans ah what do
you think of this theory I think you
just struck my ego and that felt
wonderful I think well then I challenge
that with saying what about Belle okay
you know what I mean I think Val equally
has his fan base and is a no name on the
show and also any of them really but Val
and I think have been around the longest
out other than Cheryl Chell and also I
challenge you that was Cheryl so whilst
that feels really good to me right and
right about here and strokes my ego and
makes me want to smile
I think wonderful but probably not okay
and then we don't think it's budget
either can't be budget I wasn't I was on
par with people definitely not the the
most expensive and certainly not by an
amount that would break the show if they
kept me yeah Shana speaking out on her
surprise Dancing with the Stars exit
what really happened what's next and
should we expect her in the ballroom
this season it's been a whirlwind yeah
yeah how are you I'm good I'm doing
great I am equally terrified and excited
of all the things that lay ahead of me
or possibly lay ahead of me and I am you
know currently adjusting to a a new full
season policy so when one door closes
several doors so it been so it seemed I
got the really super sad phone call that
was a is this real life moment for me I
was driving on the freeway on my way to
a meeting I was chatting with our
executive producer and I could hear it
the minute he got on the phone and his
voice I was like when was this
compared to when the announcement a day
or two before we were supposed to start
rehearsal Eve it was the Friday but it
may have been the Thursday it was the
same day that I'd haven't got the phone
call within an hour of each other and we
were supposed to go into rehearsals for
GMA because I too was getting the texts
about be ready for this and the why not
I came back early from a retreat in
Sedona just to
make sure that I was ready to do things
and they got moved but that happens wait
so up until this point though you really
thought I'm gonna be on the season
you're excited and remember you told me
I'm going for back-to-back absolutely
yeah yeah okay that was that was still
the plan until this funko happened and I
spoke to Andrew our executive producer
and again I could hear it in his voice
from the minute the phone call started
and my adrenaline spiked I'm driving on
the freeway and I was like I need to
pull over focus right now and so I
pulled over and he he let me know that
they they love me I'm very much a part
of the family of Dancing with the Stars
but they couldn't partner me up with a
partner this season and would you say
when he said that I honestly was in
shell shock I was still trying to
process it was a real mi dreaming moment
because it was such a shock to me there
was no hint that this would be the case
and there never is by the way we all go
through the same thing every season we
don't know if we're back until we get
that pick up letter and I've been
sitting pretty comfortable for a while
and you know maybe a fan favorite I mean
truly a fan favorite I thank you and we
have incredible fans I think we have a
lot of fan favorites on the Charlatans
and it's still a beautiful wonderful
cast but it was a it was a very
surprising phone call for me but at the
same time I got off that phone call and
I was very sad and I had to process take
a few minutes get back on the freeway
and go to this meeting and I walked into
this meeting with someone I'm actually
developing another show concept with and
then who also said awesome I have two
other shows that I want to talk to you
about and I was like okay universe I
hear you there are some other things
that I need to try right now you're
opening up space for me to do this I
wouldn't have had these opportunities
had I have not had the last eight and a
half years with this beautiful show
Dancing with the Stars right okay I'm
ready I've been I've been challenged
over the universe said put your money
where your mouth is no let's go do the
things you talked about so okay yeah did
they ever give you any sort of reason
honestly NART not beyond we couldn't
partner you up this season and what's
tough about hearing that is evidence
with everyone from Andy Dick to Bobby
burns to a Backstreet Boy there is no
type right so and it has nothing to do
with height and it has nothing to do
with anything so for whatever reason the
the people in the room that decide who's
on the cast felt that I wasn't what they
wanted for this version of the show and
that's okay right because the the team
in there has changed not everybody can
love you not everybody's gonna vibe with
you maybe they don't want a redhead this
season you know there's three blondes
and three brunettes I think maybe I
stick out like a sore thumb and they
don't want that or maybe it's that my
choreography they kind of got bored with
who knows and it doesn't matter it
really doesn't matter because at the end
I'm never gonna know the real reason
behind it and it's to be honest
irrelevant it's happened I'm here I've
been given an opportunity of 12 months
of other adventures yeah and who knows
what's gonna happen next year whether
they want me back or they don't or is
this the end I have honestly no idea
that's their call have you talked to
them about possibly coming back for next
season do you have a bad taste in your
mouth after all of this I definitely
don't have a bad taste but I am sad I am
sad that for me if if hypothetically
this was my last season with Bobby wow
what a wonderful way to go out and
having one with him and and their friend
that I made in him too but not having
the opportunity to know that it was my
last season or after so long going on my
own terms and being able to go around to
all of our crew members and all of our
camera guys and everybody in wardrobe
everyone who the last eight and a half
years has been my family has wrangled me
when needed to has helped me understand
learn over these years and together
we've created this beautiful show I have
so much gratitude for every single
person with even the follow spot up and
the rafters you know they they help you
see my face you know without everybody
in that room we don't get to make that
show and so I would have loved that
chance to know and you know we just
savor every moment if you know that it's
gonna be the last of it that I wish I
had a little bit and I think you deserve
that and I think people are mostly
shocked because you are the reigning
champ like that is wild I'm not gonna
it's wild but yeah I don't have any
answer for that but what a Bobby say cuz
Bobby told us that he called the show to
make sure it wasn't his fault and I know
he always gives good advice he's a good
guy what have you guys talked about he's
an amazing guy
honestly it's he did call them when we
when we briefly spoke it was like
honestly I was at a bit of a loss I
don't know I'm hearing these things I'm
hearing those things but that's also
what I was just seeing on social media
you know and there's still a train of
people that are wild about the fact that
Bobby and I won and that we broke the
show and we're the reason that there's
no spring season which is true but who
knows again at the end of the day I've I
think even no answer other than they
just couldn't pay me up this season I
was gonna ask you if this is the first
time that somebody hasn't been asked
back after winning that I don't know I
know there are people that have done it
by choice I don't know if there was ever
anyone that wasn't asked back after
winning who knows I've been texts some
of my producers and I was like am i
difficult like what is it is it is there
something that I've done wrong here in
my first 24 hours of trying to process
this and they were all like we love you
you're so good at giving story you're so
easy to work with you know how to
deliver or anything that we need and you
bring out the best in your partner so
absolutely not no just because I'm not
there for the season I'm not competing
it doesn't mean that these guys are any
less than my family I will absolutely go
I will absolutely support
I can't wait to cheer them on in the
audience so you say you're gonna be in
the bottom are gonna be there premiere
night I want to I'm hoping to there is a
something else that I may have to do I
if I can get out in time I will if it's
not the premiere cuz I know Bobby's
going and I want to meet exactly yeah
but if I can't do that then it will be
the following week so you're gonna be
watching this season - absolutely
we talked to our demand he said it's
gonna be too hard to watch just because
of all the emotions and the frustration
and maybe that'll change for him as the
season progresses but it's no one saying
it's not gonna be hard you know even
walking into CBS Studios or driving into
the lot there is there is a loss there
because it's been a part of my life for
so long
but I can't be selfish about that and I
can't wallow in that I can only look at
what this shows given me for the last
eight and a half years I can only say
thank you and go with gratitude whether
this is the end or not who knows but and
give some love back to it as well at the
same time you know through the people
and through supporting for it there is
no animosity for me there's no shade
there's there's definitely sadness yes
but that's normal that's gonna happen
I'd be lying if I said I wasn't sad be
terrible if I wasn't sad actually and
I'm sad I don't get to give the
transformative power of dance to a
person for that journey and create all
the things but there are other ways to
create all the things I do want to ask
about your lunch with Tom's dog
what did he say to you he was we had a
great catch up and he asked me even he's
like do you know why is there a reason I
was like honestly I've been given no
reason there's nothing that I can tell
you there's I've asked people no one can
give me an answer and we were just very
very sad and we had a little chat about
some of the controversy he got caught up
in a little bit there and well the xiong
space yeah I am a little bit happy or
not paired with Shaun I would struggle
regardless of whether you are or are not
a supporter of Shaun right whoever is
Dancing with him is going to I mean I
would be terrified to open my social
media because people were either for you
were against you and she's going to
unfortunately be in that world and
she'll post a photo of him and some
people are gonna love it and some people
are going to hate it more so than any
other partner on the show and I think
that whoever his partner is has a very
very big job ahead of them and is gonna
need to be able to separate themselves
from other people's opinion off this guy
I would really struggle with that that
would be really really tough any chance
that he'll be like a cameo from you
maybe has that been talked about I would
love to and I certainly wouldn't say no
to it either and if it lines up that
they want me to and I can I would love
to go into a little performance for them
or choreograph and a big number I'm down
to do all the things well you just did
so you think you can dance with Artem
and there's two more shows one was
actually yesterday which is a favorite
show of mine I can't say it until I'm
confirmed like I don't want to say I
don't want to put it out there until
isn't sure you've done before no it's
not having a dance show it's it's a
drama TV series looking back at what you
haven't done was dancing how do you feel
about that journey oh my gosh it's been
epic yeah like I struggle to find
another word for it it's the last eight
and a half years I've grown into not
just a different a better version of
myself but my craft and my art and
discovering truly I think this is where
I understood the transformative power of
dance because it always did it for me
but being able to see that happen for
other people for Noah Galloway for James
Hinchcliffe for Nick Carter for there
were so many people that went on a
journey and discovered things deep
inside themselves and worked through
them Bobby burns as well it has been
such a special thing for me to be able
to give that to other people miss most
absolutely I will get to create all the
things whether it is my own show or this
or that or someone else's quarry or
whatever it is but it won't ever be that
experience that only ever lives on
Dancing with the Stars and I am again
it's only grateful I got to do it for
eight and a half years my soul could do
it for another eight and a half you know
you never get over that
yeah it's it's such a beautiful gift
especially when you're an artist and a
creator before we wrap up mmm do you
have a message to your fans oh I'll get
a motion so supportive you and they love
you so much
okay they're gonna get emotional saying
these things um thank you so much for
all of the love and the support and in
the words of how much you miss me and
you're defending me like my champions
with her if you feel it's unjust but
what I I do want to say to you is that
it is all love and it's all gratitude
and we got a beautiful eight and a half
years of me being on this incredible
show and getting to create and no one
has ever said that it's the end and
whether it is that I come back and do
another season or not I'm always gonna
be putting things out there for you guys
I love and appreciate you all so much
you're in my heart I have a vested
interest in you all and I'm trying to
create things too for you and to help
affect change in this world especially
for women and that's all that's all
things that are coming but it was all
inspired by you guys and thank you and
even though it hurts and I'm sad to be
gone and it's a sole point feeling the
love and the energy from all of you
certainly does does help and does make
it feel better so thank you thank you
thank you and I love you